ASSEMBLY MEMBER O'DONNELL.
NOTICES THE ABSENCE OF A QUORUM
. THE SERGEANTS AT ARMS WILL
PREPARE THE CHAMBER AND BRING IN
THE ABSENT MEMBERS AND THE CLERK
WILL CALL THE ROLL. AGUIAR-CURRY
ARAMBULA BARRICADE HIM BENNETT
BERMAN BIGELOW BLOOM
BOERNER HORVATH BONTA BRIAN
CALDERON RIO CERVANTES CHEN CHOI
COOLEY COOPER CUNNINGHAM DALLY
DAILY DAVIES FLORA MIKE FONG
VINCE FONG FRIEDMAN GABRIEL
GALLAGHER CRISTINA GARCIA
EDUARDO GARCIA GIPSON GRAY
GRAYSON HOLDEN IRWIN JONES
SAWYER KALRA KILEY LACKEY LIII
LEVINE LOW MAIENSCHEIN MATHIS
MAYES MCCARTY MEDINA MULLIN
MURATSUCHI NAZARIAN. WHEN ANIL
LISTEN PETRIE-NORRIS CORK
QUIRK-SILVA RAMOS REYES
THREE OF US ROBERT RIVAS
RODRIGUEZ RUBIO SALAS SANTIAGO
SEYARTO SMITH STONE TEAM HELLO
THERE AS THE APPROVED ROCK
VOEPEL WALDRON WARD WEBER WICKS
WOOD MISTER SPEAKER.
MEMBERS. A QUORUM IS PRESENT. A
QUORUM IS PRESENT IN THE
ASSEMBLY. WE ASK THAT OUR GUESTS
AND VISITORS IN THE REAR OF THE
CHAMBER AND IN THE GALLERY.
PLEASE STAND FOR THE PRAYER.
DAZE PRAYER WILL BE OFFERED BY
OUR ASSEMBLY CHAPLAIN IMAM YASIR
KHAN IMAM YASIR. IN THE NAME OF
GOD. THE MOST GRACIOUS THE MOST
MERCIFUL. ALMIGHTY GOD SUSTAINED
IN US A DEEP SENSE OF JUSTICE.
INCLINE OUR HEARTS TO WORK FOR
THE BETTERMENT OF ALL. AND
PLEASE FOR THE HUMAN FROM FAMILY
. KEEP ALIVE IN US THE MEMORY OF
ALL THOSE WHO MADE THE ULTIMATE
SACRIFICE IS FOR OUR BENEFIT AS
A NATION. BLESS THIS LAND WITH
PROSPERITY. TEACHERS TO
CELEBRATE OUR DIFFERENCES AND TO
UNITE AROUND OUR COMMON VALUES.
BE PRESENT WITH US IN OUR HOMES
OUR PLACES OF WORK. WE THANK YOU
LORD FOR THIS DAY AND
OPPORTUNITY TO SERVE YOU BY
SERVING OTHERS. I MEAN. THANK
YOU MA'AM YES SIR WE ASK OUR
GUESTS AND VISITORS TO REMAIN
STANDING. AND JOIN US FOR THE
FLAG SALUTE PLEASE JOIN ASSEMBLY
MEMBER FLORIDA AS HE LEADS US IN
THE PLEDGE MISTER FLOOR. ALL
THESE GERMAN THE PLEDGE I PLEDGE
ALLEGIANCE TO THE FLAG. OKAY.
ZERO ONE- THE HOUSES FOR ALL.
THANK YOU MAY BE SEATED. READING
OF THE PREVIOUS DAY'S JOURNAL.
ASSEMBLY GERMAN SACRAMENTO
MONDAY FEBRUARY FOURTEENTH
TWENTY TWENTY TO THE ASSEMBLY
ABOUT AT ONE PM THE AUDIBLE
KEVIN MULLIN SPEAKER PRO TEMPORE
AB ASSEMBLY PRESIDING SHE PLUCKS
YOU PART OF THE DESK READING FOR
DAVID BOWMAN READING ROLL CALL
THE ROLL IS CALLED MAYES RAISE
THOSE AND MISTER FLORA. SECONDS
THE READING OF THEPREVIOUS
DAY'S JOURNAL BE DISPENSED WITH
PRESENTATIONS THAT PETITIONS
THERE ARE NONE. INTRODUCTION
REFERENCE OF BILLS BE DEFERRED.
REPORTS OF COMMITTEES WILL BE
DEEMED READ AND AMENDMENTS
DEEMED ADOPTED. MESSAGES FROM
THE GOVERNOR THERE ARE NONE.
MESSAGES FROM THE SENATE. THERE
ARE NONE. MOVIE TO MOTIONS AND
RESOLUTIONS THE ABSENCES FOR
TODAY FOR LEGISLATIVE BUSINESS
ASSEMBLY MEMBER LEVINE. FOR
ILLNESS ASSEMBLY MEMBERS QUIRK
AND SAY ARE TELL. WE ARE MOVING
TO PROCEDURAL MOTIONS HIS RACE
YOU ARE RECOGNIZED FOR YOUR
PROCEDURAL MOTIONS THANK YOU
MISTER SPEAKER I REQUEST
UNANIMOUS CONSENT TO SUSPEND
ASSEMBLY RULE FORTY FIVE POINT
FIVE TO ALLOW ASSEMBLYMEMBERS
GALLAGHER DOLLY. WHEN AND WHEN
TO SPEAK ON AND ADJOURNMENTS IN
MEMORY TODAY. WITHOUT OBJECTION
SUCH SHALL BE THE ORDER.
MEMBERS. MEMBERS WE HAVE A
NUMBER OF. BIRTHDAYS. TODAY IS
ASSEMBLY MEMBER THE APPROVED WAS
BIRTHDAY. AND SATURDAY MARCH
TWELFTH IT'S ASSEMBLY MEMBER
SALAS AND ASSEMBLY MEMBER
LACKEYS BIRTHDAY HAPPY BIRTHDAY
GENTLEMEN.
MEMBERS WE ARE MOVING TO
BUSINESS ON THE DAILY FILE.
SECOND READING CORRECT ASSEMBLY
BILL FIFTY NINETY EIGHT WITH A
MINUTE 1-682-174-0417 EIGHTY TWO
WITH SOME PEOPLE SIXTEEN THIRTY
WITH A MINUTE SIXTEEN NINETY
EIGHT WITH AMENDMENTS AND
ASSEMBLY BILL SEVENTY NO SIX
WITH AMENDMENTS. ALL BILLS WILL
BE DEEMED READ. AND AMENDMENTS
DEEMED ADOPTED.
MEMBERS REGARDING THE
AFOREMENTIONED ASSEMBLY MEMBER
BE APPROVED WHILE. I HAVE SOME
BREAKING NEWS THAT THERE ARE
TREATS BEING PROVIDED IN THE
MEMBERS LOUNGE AT THIS TIME.
THAT'S TREATS IN THE MEMBERS
LOUNGE COURTESY. ASSEMBLY MEMORY
VALLAPUDUA THANK YOU SIR.
THAT OF COURSE. THE STREETS ARE
AVAILABLE AFTER SESSION. I'M
GETTING MORE INFORMATION THIS
AFTER SESSION THE STREETS WILL
BE AVAILABLE THANK YOU. WE ARE
ON BUSINESS ON THE DAILY FILE A
RECONSIDERATION FILE ITEM NUMBER
EIGHT SHALL BE CONTINUED FILE
ITEM NUMBER NINE. ASSEMBLY THIRD
READING FILE ITEM NUMBER NINE
SHALL BE PASSED RETAIN. AND ON
SENATE THIRD READING FILE ITEMS
TEN. THROUGH THIRTEEN. ALSO PASS
AND RETAIN. WE DO NOT HAVE A
CONSENT CALENDAR TODAY.
MEMBERS I HAVE A NUMBER OF
ANNOUNCEMENTS UNRELATED TO
TREATS. MEMBERS I'M ORDERING THE
DEATHS TO BE HELD OPEN TO
RECEIVE AUTHORS AMENDMENTS WE
HAVE SEVERAL COMMITTEE HEARINGS
THIS AFTERNOON THE JOINT HEARING
OF ASSEMBLY BUSINESS AND
PROFESSIONS AND SENATE BUSINESS
PROFESSIONS AND ECONOMIC
DEVELOPMENT WILL MEET UPON
ADJOURNMENT OF ASSEMBLY AND
SENATE SESSIONS IN THE SENATE
CHAMBER. IN A JOINT LEGISLATIVE
COMMITTEE ON CLIMATE CHANGE
POLICIES WILL MEET UPON
ADJOURNMENT OF ASSEMBLY AND
SENATE FLOOR SESSIONS IN ROOM
FORTY TWO- TO.
MEMBERS OF THE QUORUM CALL IS IN
PLACE WE'RE KEEPING THE QUORUM
CALL IN PLACE AT THIS TIME. WE
ARE MOVING TO ADJOURNMENTS IN
MEMORY. MEMBERS I WOULD ASK THAT
YOU PLEASE TAKE YOUR SEATS. THEY
GIVE RESPECTFUL ATTENTION TO
YOUR COLLEAGUES WHO ARE CHURNING
IN THE MEMORY. PLEASE TAKE YOUR
CONVERSATIONS OFF OF THE FLOOR.
MEMBERS WHERE GERMAN TO MEMORY
THE QUORUM CALL IS IN PLACE.
PLEASE TAKE YOUR SEATS ORTEGA
CONVERSATIONS OFF OF THE GREEN
CARPET MEMBERS.
MEMBERS PLEASE TAKE YOUR SEATS
OR TAKE YOUR CONVERSATIONS OFF
OF THE FLOOR. THANK YOU MEMBERS. THE FOLLOWING MEMBERS MORE
GRANTED PRIOR PERMISSIONTO
SPEAK ON A GERMAN IN MEMORY.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER GALLAGHER YOU
ARE RECOGNIZED FOR YOUR
ADJOURNMENTS IN MEMORY. THANK
YOU MISTER SPEAKER MEMBERS I
RISE THIS MORNING TO ADJOURN IN
MEMORY OF FORMER TRIBAL CHAIRMAN
OF MORE TOWN RANCHERIA GARY ARCH
ALETTA. GARY WAS BORN ON JULY
EIGHTEENTH NINETEEN FIFTY THE
OLDEST OF FIVE CHILDREN. HE WAS
A NORMAL BOY HE'S ATTENDED ALL
ORVILLE SCHOOLS TO GRADUATION
AND LATER JOINED OUR ARMED
SERVICES IN THE U. S. AIR FORCE
TO SERVE A FIVE YEAR TOUR. GARY
WAS VERY PROUD OF HIS SERVICE.
ON BEHALF OF OUR COUNTRY. HE WAS
A VALUED EMPLOYEE OF THE CITY OF
ORVILLE PARKS DEPARTMENT FOR
TWENTY TWO YEARS. AND MONEY WHAT
ENDED HIS SERVICE TO THE CITY.
HE WAS ELECTED VICE CHAIRMAN. OF
THE MORE TOWN RANCHERIA. IN TWO
THOUSAND AND ONE HE WAS ELECTED
CHAIRMAN. OF THE TRIBE. HE
SERVED THE MIGHTY TRIBE
HONORABLY FOR TWENTY YEARS.
SEEING THE TRIED TO CONTINUED
GROWTH UNTIL HIS RETIREMENT IN
DECEMBER OF TWENTY SIXTEEN. GARY
WAS AN ACTIVE PARTICIPANT A
LOCAL STATE AND FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT WORKING HARD TO
ENSURE TRIBAL SELF GOVERNANCE.
HE WAS ALSO CRITICAL IN HELPING
TO ESTABLISH. A FIRE DEPARTMENT
THROUGH THE MORE TOWN RANCHERIA-
THAT WAS CRITICAL IN FIGHTING
WILDLAND FIRES IN THE REGION. IS
AN ACTIVE HE WAS A HUMBLE AND
KIND AND GENEROUS MAN WHO FELT
STRONGLY ABOUT IMPROVING THE
OPPORTUNITIES. FOR HIS TRIBE BUT
ALL INDIGENOUS PEOPLE. HE SERVED
ON COMMITTEES AND BOARDS FOR THE
CALIFORNIA NATIONS INDIAN GAMING
ASSOCIATION. NORTHERN CIRCLE
INDIAN HOUSING AUTHORITY AND THE
FEATHER RIVER TRAVEL HEALTH. HE
APPEARED IN COMMERCIALS
SUPPORTING INDIAN GAMING AT A
TIME WHEN THE ISSUE WAS ON
CALIFORNIA STATE BALLOTS. AND HE
REMAINED A CHAMPION OF TRIBAL
SOVEREIGNTY THROUGHOUT HIS
CAREER AND LIFE. JERRY IS
SURVIVED BY HIS LOVING WIFE
CONNIE TWO DAUGHTERS CATHERINE
AND ANGELA SEVEN GRANDCHILDREN
AND FOUR GREAT GRANDCHILDREN HIS
SISTER LINDA EDWARDS AND THREE
BROTHERS GERALD MICHAEL AND
DENNIS ARCHULETA. AND A WHOLE
BUNCH OF FAMILY NIECES NEPHEWS
COUSINS TRIBAL MEMBERS WHO LOVE
THIS MAN AND EVERYTHING HE DID
FOR. THE MORE TOWN RANCHERIA AND
FOR THE COMMUNITY OF OROVILLE
AND FOR REALLY HIS SERVICE TO
THE STATE LARGE. MANY PEOPLE
WERE ABLE TO CALL HIM THEIR
FRIEND AND HE WILL TRULY BE
MISSED BY ALL. THANK YOU MEMBERS
AN ASSET WE ADJOURN IN MEMORY OF
GARY ARCH ALETTA. THANK YOU MISS
GALLAGHER AND MS DALY YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED. THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER TODAY I ALSO RISE TO
HONOR GARY ARCHULETA A COMMUNITY
LEADER FROM NORTHERN CALIFORNIA
WHO ABSENCE WHOSE ABSENCE WILL
BE FELT BY MANY. YOU CARE DEEPLY
FOR USE AND IMPROVING THE
COMMUNITY FOR THE NEXT
GENERATION HE WILL BE REMEMBERED
FOR HIS KINDNESS HIS GENEROSITY
THE WAY HE ADVOCATED FOR
INDIGENOUS PEOPLE AND ALL THOSE
IN HIS COMMUNITY. THANK YOU FOR
JOINING ME TODAY AND REMEMBERING
A GREAT MAN HE WILL BE DEEPLY
MISSED BY HIS FAMILY AND FRIENDS
AND TRIBAL COMMUNITIES THANK YOU
MEMORY THANK YOU MEMBERS FOR.
HONORING GARY TODAY AND I HAD
THE OPPORTUNITY OF SPENDING TIME
WITH HIM WHEN THE BOYS TO MEN IN
COLOR. CAME ON TO THE DISTRICT
AND I WAS DEEPLY MOVED BY HIS-
ADVOCACY FOR THE TRIBAL USE AND
HE HE WAS JUST AN AMAZING MAN
SO. THANK YOU FOR HONORING HIM.
THANK YOU MISSPELLING. MISSION
WHEN YOU ARE RECOGNIZED FOR YOUR
GERMAN IN MEMORY. I THINK THANK
YOU MISTER SPEAKER AND
COLLEAGUES I RISE TODAY TO ASK
THEIR WAGER IN MEMORY OF GERMANY
AND JOSH WHAT PAGE OF
WESTMINSTER EARLIER THIS WEEK
OUR QUEUE ME WAS ONCE AGAIN
WALKED BY ANOTHER TRAGIC LOSS
GERMAN JOSH WEBPAGE FROM
WESTMINSTER TO BRIGHT AND
PROMISING HIGH SCHOOL YOUNG MEN
WERE TAKEN FROM THEIR FAMILIES
AND FRIENDS TO SUIT. ON THE
MORNING OF MONDAY MARCH SEVENTH
THE PAGE BROTHERS WERE ON THEIR
WAY TO SCHOOL WHEN THE TRUCK
COLLIDED WITH ANOTHER TRUCK. AT
A BUSY INTERSECTION IN HUNT TO
BEACH. JOSH WAS SAD AND LOST HIS
LIFE UPON IMPACT. AND HIS
YOUNGER BROTHER. JEREMY PASSED
AWAY THE FOLLOWING MORNING. JOSH
WELL AUTHOR PAGE WAS BORN ON
JUNE SIXTEENTH TWO THOUSAND
THREE. TO JOHN AND SHADIA PAGE
JOINING HIS OLDER BROTHER
GIOVANNI. SHORTLY AFTER THE PAGE
FAMILY WELCOME GERMANY ART PAGE
BORN ON OCTOBER SIXTH TWO
THOUSAND FOUR. THE PAGE BROTHERS
WERE RAISED IN THE CATHOLIC
CHURCH IN ATTENDING CATHOLIC
SCHOOLS. THE FAMILY ATTENDED
SAINT VINCENT DE PAUL. WE'RE ALL
THREE SERVE AS ALTAR BOYS AND
WERE FETCHING KNOWN AS THE THREE
MARCH I. JOSHUA WAS AN
ACCOMPLISHED STUDENT ATHLETES
AND PLAY FOR YEARS ON THE EDISON
HIGH SCHOOL VERSUS. FOOTBALL
TEAM AND TWO YEARS. ON THE
SCHOOL'S WRESTLING TEAM. JOSH
WAS ALSO AN EAGLE SCOUT AND
COMPLETED HIS SERVICE PROJECT A
GARDEN VIEW ELEMENTARY SCHOOL.
AFTER HIGH SCHOOL HE WAS
DETERMINED TO SERVE OUR GREAT
COUNTRY. IN THE IN THE UNITED
STATES NAVY AND HAD A DREAM OF
BECOMING UNDERWATER WELDER. MOST
WHO KNEW GERMANY WOULD DESCRIBE
HIM AS A RESERVE AND FOCUSED.
DESPITE BEING THE OLDER BROTHER
JOSH WILL LOOK UP TO VISIT TO
GERMANY FOR HIS KINDNESS AND
CARING WAYS TO WITH FRIENDS AND
STRANGERS ALIKE. LIKE HIS
BROTHER JEREMY WAS THE WAS
WORKING TO BECOME AN EAGLE SCOUT
IT WAS ALSO THE CHIEF STUDENT
ATHLETE IN HIS OWN RIGHT. AS A
MEMBER OF THE EDUCATE. EDISON
HIGH SCHOOL FOOTBALL AND THE
TRACK AND FIELD TEAM JEREMY
LOVED ANIMALS AND WANTED TO
BECOME A MARINE BIOLOGIST. NO
PARENT SHOULD EVER HAVE TO KNOW.
WHAT IT IS LIKE TO LOSE A CHILD
GET A LOAN TO. AS A MOTHER OF
TWO YOUNG BOYS MYSELF. MY HEART
GOES OUT TO THEIR PARENTS. AND
THEIR BROTHER. PLEASE JOIN ME IN
SENDING OUT PRAYERS AND
CONDOLENCES TO THE PAGE FAMILY.
JEREMY AND JOSH WAS TEAMMATES
AND CLASSMATES IN THE COMMUNION
LARGE WHO HAVE ALL BEEN AFFECTED
BY THIS TRAGIC LOSS. OF TWO.
BRIGHT AND PROMISING YOUNG MEN
WHOSE LIVES WERE TAKEN WAY TOO
SOON THANK YOU. THANK YOU MISTER
WHEN. MEMBERS PLEASE BRING THE
NAMES TO THE DESK TO BE PRINTED
IN THE JOURNAL. OUR QUESTION
JOURNAL MEMORY WILL BE DEEMED
READ A PRINTED IN THE JOURNAL.
SESSION SCHEDULES AS FOLLOWS
FRIDAY MARCH ELEVENTH NO FLOOR
SESSION NO CHECK IN SESSION
MONDAY MARCH FOURTEENTH FLOOR
SESSION AT ONE PM. ALL OTHER
ITEMS REMAINING WILL BE PASSED
RETAIN ALL MOTION SHALL BE
CONTINUED SEEING HER IN A FOR
THE BUSINESS I'M READY TO
ENTERTAIN A MOTION TO ADJOURN.
MS REYES MOVES. MR COOLEY
SECONDS THAT THIS HOUSE KIDS
JOURNAL MONDAY MARCH FOURTEENTH
AT ONE PM. IN THE QUORUM CALL IS
LIFTED.